foreign
hello welcome to the Google Cloud
security showcase
special web series where we'll focus on
security use cases that customers
encounter on Google cloud my name is
Connor Hammersmith and I'm on the
security Command Center go to market
team and I'm joined by Mukesh marodia
from our product management team at
Google cloud in this video on
operationalizing security Command Center
findings we'll discuss common customer
use cases and how they leverage SEC
findings to secure their Cloud
Operations Security Command Center is
Google Cloud's Flagship security product
providing visibility into Cloud assets
identifying misconfigurations and
vulnerabilities compliance reporting and
identifying security threats across your
environment
in order to take full advantage of the
valuable insights that security Command
Center can provide it is important to
understand that different findings may
have different audiences
you can curate the findings that are
sent to each User Group to avoid
overloading them with alerts
the most common use case we see is
streaming threat findings to a Sim so
that your security operations team can
properly triage and mitigate these
security events
another common use case is monitoring
misconfigurations and vulnerabilities
identified by security health Analytics
these findings are used to monitor for
potential compliance reporting issues in
real time while shifting left by trying
to get these findings into the hands of
developers before they even migrate
infrastructure to production one of the
most important aspects of
operationalizing security Command Center
findings is taking advantage of the
ability to stream security events to
third-party systems that are already
ingrained into your business processes
SEC has been built to leverage Google
Cloud's data processing expertise to
stream security events to your most
critical applications whether that is
creating new events in your sim sending
messages via slack or creating tickets
in grn service now SEC is built to meet
those use cases we also provide
out-of-the-box integration with
Chronicle and simplify to facilitate
further investigation into security
events and drive automated response and
Remediation activities when thinking
about how your organization May best
operationalize security Command Center
findings it is point is important to
under understand the SEC premium
supports the ability to provide scoped
views this allows end users to view SEC
findings that correspond to where they
are in the Google Cloud resource
hierarchy
for example accessing SEC from the
organization level will allow visibility
into findings for all projects
accessing security command center from a
folder or project will restrict findings
accordingly SEC provides multiple ways
to view findings including a high level
overview
a page specific to threat findings
the vulnerabilities page includes
posture management findings from
security health analytics and
vulnerabilities identified by our web
security scanner
the compliance page allows you to
quickly view how your infrastructure is
benchmarked against multiple regulatory
Frameworks
the findings page is a One-Stop shop for
all findings and security Command Center
the security command center team has
recently released a new and improved
user experience for the findings page
let's kick it over to makesh to walk us
through the enhanced findings UI
workflow in the console take it from
here makesh
thank you Connor I'm equally excited so
for the purpose of this demo let's say I
am a security analyst I spend majority
of my time on the finding page the new
query and quick filters is make my job
extremely easy
the quick filter on the left allows me
to look at different categories of
finding with the numbers I can pick on
the category which I'm interested in I
can look the finding by class or drill
down by project ID or resource type
which are there
in this case I'm just going to look at
all high severity finding but if I want
I can look at just the thread coming
from vmtd or look at the
misconfiguration coming from security
health analytics as I have selected
the high severity threats here the query
Builder on the top got updated but I'm
going to add few more filters from the
query Builder I could choose different
resources like container or databases or
choose a compliance regime like CIS and
go to the specific version of it in this
case I'm going to look at a miter track
technique called Cloud accounts which
I'm most interested about and apply this
filter here and I can see that on 7th of
September there are two imnr elements
Grant which was given
I'm going to look at one of them here in
the new finding page I could see
which are the service account which are
which are involved in this thread
but I can also see what was the specific
action done here here the service
account was given a role which we never
recommend
what especially useful for me is to
click on this down arrow and it shows me
all the findings associated with the
service account delegation information
upon clicking this I can see that the
filter here is getting updated
and it is going to show me all the
findings associated with that delegation
and not only I can see the numberless I
am grand but I can see that there is a
bigquery expectation here which has
happened
and apart from the service accounts
which was in question we could also see
the table from where the data is getting
exfiltrated and the target where the
data was going and very quickly will get
to the detail here
so in summary a query built on the top
the quick filter on the left and the new
finding page makes my job a lot more
easy and that concludes this demo
[Music]